This expression holds for any state s but we will specifically be using it with our variational state s of theta.
Each of the terms h alpha can be measured m times yielding measurement samples s subalpha j with j running from
1 to m and returns an expectation value and a standard deviation. We can sum
these terms and propagate errors through the sum.
This requires no largecale multiplication nor any process that necessarily scales like n squ. Instead,
it requires multiple measurements on the quantum computer. If you don't need too many of those, this approach could be
efficient. And that's the quantum part of VQE. But let's talk about reasons why this might not be efficient. One reason
for many measurements is to reduce the statistical uncertainty in your estimates for very high precision
calculations. Another reason is the number of poly strings required to span your entire matrix. Because poly matrices plus the
identity span the space of all operators of a given dimension, we are guaranteed
that we can write our matrix of interest as a weighted sum of poly operators as we did before. Here C alpha is a
numerical coefficient and H alpha is a string of poly operators acting on all the cubits describing your system.
H alpha would have a form like this where the nth poly operator from the right acts on the nth cubit. So we can
measure our operator by measuring a series of poly operators. But we cannot measure all of those poly operators
simultaneously. Poly operators excluding the identity do not commute with each other if they are
associated with the same cubit. For example, we can measure I Z IIZ and ZZ
XZ simultaneously because we can measure I and Z simultaneously for the third
cubit. And we can know I and X simultaneously for the first cubit. But we cannot
measure all Z's and Z zz ZX simultaneously because Z and X do not
commute and both act on the zeroth cubit.
So we decompose our matrix H into a sum of poly's acting on different cubits.
Some elements of that sum can be measured all at once. We call this a group of commuting polies. Depending on
how many non-commuting terms there are, we may need many such groups. Call the number of such groups of commuting
polyst.
If ngcp is small, this could work well.
If h has millions of groups, this will not be useful. You record the expectation value or the cost function
for the set of parameters theta used in your state and then you update the parameters over time. You could use the
expectation values or cost function values you've estimated to approximate a gradient of your cost function in the
subspace of states sampled by your anzots.
Both gradient-based and gradient-free classical optimizers exist. both suffer from potential trainability issues like
multiple local minima and large regions of parameter space with near zero gradient called barren plateaus.
So will VQE solve all your toughest problems? No. But being better at all calculations was never the point. We've
shifted what determines the computational cost. Look at what we've traded. We've shifted from a process
whose complexity depends only on matrix dimension to one that depends on required precision and the number of
non-commuting poly operators that make up the matrix. The last bit has no analog in classical computing.
Based on these new dependencies for sparse matrices or matrices involving few non-commuting polystrings, this
process may be useful. This is the case for systems of interacting spins. For example, for dense matrices, it may be
less useful. We know, for example, that chemical systems often have Hamiltonians that involve hundreds, thousands, even
millions of polystrings. There has been interesting work done to reduce this number of terms, but
chemical systems may be better suited to some of the other algorithms we'll discuss in this course.
Effective use of VQE also requires that we know attributes of our target state and can select a good physically
motivated initial state as well as a good anzot with relatively few variational parameters. This can be
quite challenging. VQE demonstrates how the strengths of classical and quantum computers can be combined
without adding more recent methods. VQE does not help us solve problems that are intractable for classical computers, but
it continues to play a role in algorithm development. And VQE also teaches us that transferring a step from classical
to quantum computers is neither better nor worse for all purposes. Rather, it
changes what factors determine the efficiency of your algorithm. This is an important general lesson in quantum
classical hybrid computing.